well so a few weeks ago we had a number
file video um where i reported on the
discovery of 42 as a sum of three cubes
there it is i can see it oh yeah yep
so in that video i said that we're going
to have a go at finding a representation
for three we're going to throw
everything uh we have at it we'll see
but uh you know this kind of thing you
never know it's uh a once in a
generation kind of thing okay and um
before anyone expected it um it just
popped out you've got it we've got it
yep three was already known as the sum
of three cubes wasn't it in the cup in a
couple of ways that's right uh should i
write that down yeah all right three had
two known representations as a sum of
three cubes one cubed plus one cubed
plus one cubed and also
four cubed
plus four cubed plus negative five cubed
so both of them single digits this was
the problem that kicked it all off um so
it was in 1953 that mordell asked
kind of as an offhand remark actually in
the middle of a paper about something
else he says i don't know anything about
the solutions of um this problem you
know other than the
two easy ones and it must be very hard
indeed to say anything about other
possible solutions that turned out to be
an understatement because it took 66
years to find the next one and it has a
couple numbers with 21 digits two of
them have 21 digits and the other one
has um 18. we should point out there are
some numbers that can never be found
that's right so um if your number if you
divide it by nine and you get a
remainder of four or five then uh we
know you can't do it so four five uh 13
14 et cetera but the others
it's expected there's a conjecture that
says that there ought to be infinitely
many representations as a sum of three
cubes but it's not proven no it's not
proven well so there are a few numbers
for which it is um and i think tim
talked about this in the very first
video you can write down parametric
families for the number one
um or two
okay but starting from three
and many numbers have no such parametric
families that we know of and we don't
expect them nevertheless we think that
there are infinitely many solutions
they're just kind of sporadic so the
conjecture is every number other than
that special class
has infinite number of ways to express
it as a sum of three cubes that's right
and there's even kind of a conjectured
uh density so
we expect you know there's a formula for
how many we expect roughly
up to a certain number of digits what's
special about three is that it has the
lowest expected density of any number up
to 100. so it's not so surprising that
this one was hard
nevertheless we did have to go much
further than than we would have expected
to find the third solution and just
quickly how did you find this new one
for three the same way you found 42 yeah
pretty similar um there are it turns out
there's some optimizations that are
specific to the number three that we
could do and uh more or less that let us
go another order of magnitude um for
free
uh you know over what we could do for 42
and so it was about the same size
computation
um as for 42. and you use this big
network this charity engine network yeah
we use charity engine and
to be honest we uh have yet to throw
anything at the charity into guys that
caused them to break a sweat uh so
i sent an email with a new version of
the code
around noon on a monday and uh seven
hours later i got um the email with the
solution uh partly that was down to luck
but also partly because you know charity
engine network is big i was in band
rehearsal
and you know just during break time i
checked on my phone
and saw it there and uh was really
excited um i'm pretty sure my band mates
think i'm a complete nutter now did you
tell them did you tell your band mates
well not all of them just the the ones
uh near me i tried to explain a bit yeah
did they are any of the mathematicians
or were they like no
so they were just like okay
yeah uh whatever andy yeah
why is this significant it seems like
you mean you're just knocking off one
number at a time and one new solution at
a time this like you know this could go
forever why was three
worth even doing that's right well i
mean partly it's for historical reasons
because that this is the problem that
kicked off the whole thing and it's very
satisfying too to be able to solve this
there are theoretical reasons too so
this touches on something called
hilbert's tenth problem so hilbert
made a famous list of 23 problems at the
beginning of the 20th century you know
kind of
outlining his vision for mathematics in
the coming century number 10 on the list
was to find a way of telling if
any given diophantine equation
has a solution or not so that's just a
polynomial equation and you're looking
for integer solutions at first glance
this seems pretty reasonable so in
school you learn how to solve
linear equations and quadratic equations
at university you take it up to any
number of variables um
but um it turns out so this is one of
hilbert's problems that's solved now but
probably not in the way that hilbert
envisioned it all so it's solved in the
sense that we know it's impossible
okay so um for general diophantine
equations uh it's not always possible to
solve them so there can be diophantine
equations out there that have no integer
solutions um but also no way of proving
that fact and what makes this example of
the sum of three cubes really
interesting is it's you know right at
the sweet spot for being a difficult
problem
along these lines on the one hand it's
very close to things that um that are
relatively easy that we understand
um for instance if instead of three
cubes you had three squares right um
then we have a complete characterization
of those numbers that can be written as
a sum of three squares in fact that's a
famous theorem from the end of the 18th
century
of legendre or um if instead of three
cubes i had two cubes and then again we
have a characterization of those numbers
and likewise i think if you have more
cubes then
it's not completely solved for four
cubes but there's there's lots of
progress it's it's three cubes where
it's uh really turns out to be difficult
and really nobody has any idea how to
attack this theoretically andrew i can
see why 42 was fun to do because it's 42
and it was the last one below 100. yeah
and i can see why three was worth doing
because it has this historical niceness
to it it's where it all started but for
how long can you just keep picking off
these solutions i mean when do you when
does all the attention turn to a
concrete proof that's right so um
yeah the problem is for uh given all
that we know now this might be the only
thing that we could do
um so as far as anyone knows there could
be a diophantine equation of this type
you know for instance 114 that's the
next number we don't know does it have a
representation as a sum of three cubes
it's conceivable that the answer is no
but also that there's no way to prove
that so it's a little dissatisfying but
you know that could be the case and we
don't think that's the case we think
that if you look long enough um that you
will find a solution um but nobody knows
for sure
and even that in itself could be an
undecidable problem does every number
that we think should have a
representation have such a
representation i always get very
confused when i go you know down this
rabbit hole it goes very deep but where
do you stop i mean are you searching for
114 now
we are going to so uh you know every
time i think we're finished with this
then we find it with uh think of a few
more things that um that we can do so we
are going to have a go actually i
haven't said yet we found another uh we
found a representation for 906. so that
knocked another number off the list
we're down to nine up to a thousand um
but i should say i'm quite skeptical
that we're going to solve all of the
nine remaining ones up to a thousand
anytime soon
but is there a point just continually
knocking these off the list if you think
they've all got one anyway shouldn't all
the energy be going into the proof are
you working on the proof or is that not
your area that's not my area i am
somewhat sympathetic to this yeah so the
point is to go until you're pretty sure
of what is true i think we're at that
point uh for a while that wasn't always
the case right um there was uh maybe 30
years where
um many people thought that
maybe this wasn't true you know
that there weren't any more
representations for three um or there
weren't any for some of the uh the other
small numbers 33 42 etc
now we're pretty sure that um that heath
brown's conjecture that says there are
infinite many is true we have good
evidence for that now and so at least
we're trying to prove the right thing
you probably saw in the last video lots
of people say this is cool but what's
what's the point of to keep doing this
why are you keeping doing it you say
you're pretty confident it's true
this computational power could be used
for other things why keep knocking the
numbers off the list just for
completeness yeah so we are going to
stop eventually mostly it's just a bit
of fun yeah um and uh the historical
reasons for um three and the numbers up
to a hundred that's right and you want
to finish that thousand listings right
honestly brady i'm not sure that i'll
live long enough to see the that that
wasn't done really yeah well i've had
discussions about this with my daughter
too yeah it's a bit fatalistic but yeah
she might live to see it but but i
probably won't yeah i don't know last
time we spoke about three and within
days you'd found that why do the
remaining nine ones below a thousand
have to be so unobtainable couldn't they
just be a similar number of digits or do
you think one of them has to have it's
possible but uh so i talked about this
conjecture density right and for some of
these numbers um i'd have to look up i
think it was 390 that has the lowest
density it's really small um and if you
haven't found one by a certain point um
well it's kind of like you know if you
expect your bus every 10 minutes if it's
supposed to come every 10 minutes and
you've been standing there 20 minutes at
the bus stop you still expect to wait
another 10 minutes right it's that kind
of thing so um we're
it's very likely that we'll have to go
another um seven eight you know maybe
more digits further than um we have up
to up to now
to find a representation for um 390.
where's the next three likely to be next
one for three how many that also i'm not
expecting to see anytime soon yeah um so
we expect the solutions for three on
average to get about seven digits longer
with each new solution i notice always
they the three numbers always have a
similar number of digits
is that so this one was a little
peculiar so uh it was quite extreme um
well it was very skewed so the the first
two numbers were nearly equal in size um
but opposite in sign so that they they
almost cancel each other out and then
the third variable was small right just
to make up the difference
that happens uh a fair amount of time
actually so one feature of the new
algorithm that we're using as opposed to
earlier attempts is that it only matters
what the size of the smallest number is
right so if we had to do a search that
went all the way out to finding the
biggest numbers then we wouldn't have
been able to do it the technology we
have now
is it possible there's a solution for
three
with smaller numbers that you've brushed
past uh it's possible it depends on what
you mean by smaller so there shouldn't
be any um with um the smallest number
smaller than the one we found but
because the first two numbers are so
enormous um in in the solution that we
found that it is conceivable that
there's a solution where the total digit
size over all the numbers is smaller
yeah how are you feeling about this i i
feel pretty good yeah it's quite
satisfying um and i think we're nearing
a sense of closure on this problem but
uh let me turn it around and ask how you
feel brady well i i know the number five
video
like nudged you to look into this so i
feel like
like
like some sort of naught point nor one
percent involved oh yeah come on you're
being modest so uh i would say that
numberphile's contribution has been as
important um as mine or anyone else's
who's worked on this
um so in fact each video gave us just
the boost that we needed to and to
tackle the next challenge um starting
with the first one you know with tim
browning i mean maybe this number
doesn't belong on a list why is the
number on the list if we haven't got a
solution
that's a very good question and there
have been some attempts to prove that
this number
isn't on the list but
those terms have failed that got some
sender who spends attention who read a
bigger search and found 74.
sander huseman has gone away and
calculated a new solution to one integer
that's previously unknown whether it was
a sum of three cubes or not and then it
was that video on that on 74 that really
um got me into it and it found 33. we
found three integers whose cube sum to
33. there's always another number um for
us the next one is 42. and then you know
the publicity around that and with a
video on 33 that
attracted the attention of charity
engine and
andrew sutherland also and then we've
just uh pushed further and further so
it's you know it's been kind of a domino
effect a highly improbable sequence of
events what about that elusive like
rigorous proof though yeah that takes um
mathematicians who work in um
diophantine equations
algebraic geometry to focus harder on
this
that's not something you can predict so
it takes a new idea beyond you know an
idea that no one has ever had
to solve equations like this
theoretically
do you have any correspondence with
those sort of people like will you tell
them about this new number and hope to
encourage them uh tim browning is the
closest yeah
we'll get and we'll get in touch with
him yeah
yeah so maybe we'll look for the next
for the parker square now or something
like that
you can get yourself a 42 t-shirt or
hoodie from our merch store see the
links in the usual spots and also thanks
to our patreon supporters 42 of whom
some of them randomly selected are being
sent one of these 42 mementos signed by
andrew himself
this is one seriously nerdy collector's
item you can support us at
patreon.com slash number file we're
always trying to do new little extra
things to show our appreciation